now to ukraine where russia is closer to
capturing an eastern city that ukraine's
president says could be decisive in the
outcome of the war reports say the
troops are fighting house to house now
and soon there may be no way for
remaining civilians to get out
chris livesay went to a village
recaptured by ukraine where people are
still afraid of the russians
it's cherry season in novo veronsovka
but there's hardly anyone left to pick
them
valentina is moved to tears as we
approach how often is the shelling going
on
every day she sighs
so your windows have been bombed out it
must've been terrifying
valentina's only company left is her
baby goat bjelka originally from russia
valentina is exactly the kind of person
vladimir putin says he wants to liberate
russia is attacking ukraine's food with
medieval cruelty burning crops and
cutting off water but it's also the
world's food says secretary of state
anthony blinken somewhere around 20
million tons of wheat that's trapped in
silos near odessa and in ships literally
filled with grain that are stuck in the
odessa port because of this russian
blockade
in other words quite simply put
it's blackmail
blackmail against the west to stop
supporting ukraine or risk what the u.n
is calling a hurricane of global hunger
ukraine's forces are now locked in close
quarter battles in the city of severo
donetsk lose it and they lose the region
of luhansk but further south ukraine is
clawing back territory
these towns in the kerasan region had
been under russian occupations since the
start of the war today they're once
again free for those alive to see it
these are lives that could have been
saved says president zielinski begging
the west to deliver the weapons it's
promised
did we get them
now those weapons are crucial for two
major reasons the first is to protect
cities here in the east like severo
donetsk which could fall any day and the
second is to protect ukraine's coast
where all of that food is blocked if the
weapons don't get here in time then
millions of tons risk rotting in the
ports gail
that's not good news thank you very much
chris chris lipsey reporting from
ukraine this morning